[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich habe heute einen sonntags kuchen
gebacken und zwar einen bienenstich aber
keinen klassischen vielen stich sondern
eine abgewandelte er herzliche version
ich habe hier den ganz normalen hefeteig
zubereitet und habe dann warnschüsse
hier oben drauf gegeben statt
mandelblättchen und dem innern habe ich
eine buttercreme mit apfel also mit
apfelsaft gemacht und dann noch
apfelkompott gemacht und das ganze ist
wirklich sehr herbstlich sehr fruchtig
auch und wirklich sehr lecker ich zeige
euch jetzt zuerst einmal wie ich den
hefeteig zubereitet habe und dann geht's
anschließend auch an die füllung für den
hefeteig brauche ich einen halben würfel
hefe zwei esslöffel warmes wasser 40 g
zucker 250 gramm mehl 125 milliliter
lauwarme milch einen viertel teelöffel
salz 1 41 kam zerlassene butter
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die hefe
die geht jetzt direkt in die
rührschüssel dazu kommt das warme wasser
und das zucker und jetzt kann ich die
zutaten einmal kurz berühren
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt die restlichen zutaten
mit reindl dann auch die milch alles ist
ganz wichtig beim hefeteig dass ein und
auch die butter und dann kann ich jetzt
den hefeteig in etwa fünf bis sieben
minuten geschmeidig kneten entweder
könnt ihr das mit der hand machen oder
ganz einfach mit der küchenmaschine
[Musik]
der teig ist fertig und das ist ein
bisschen weiterer teig also von der
konsistenz lasse ich den gerne etwas
weicher reifen später einfach in die
backform dann eingießen den denke ich
jetzt abnehmen dafür jetzt das früher
element hier weg und dann kann ich eben
für eine stunde aufgehen lassen
und die zwischenzeit kann ich aber schon
nutzen um den pudding herzustellen und
auch den muss belag für den pudding
traurig 500 milliliter apfelsaft es ist
ein naturtrüber einen teelöffel zimt 250
g 20 kampfstärke 125 gramm weiche butter
und für das apfel komforth brauche ich
zwei äpfel der sentry burnett etwas
vanille extrakt den saft einer halben
zitrone 50 milliliter apfelsaft und 40
gramm zucker
zuerst werde ich jetzt den pudding
herstellen und dafür nehme ich jetzt
keine milch sondern wie eben schon
gezeigt apfelsaft den gebe ich jetzt in
einer talk und lasst ihr jetzt einfach
mal aufkochen und um die hälfte
reduzieren also dass ihm am ende nur
noch 250 milliliter saft da sind das
kann ich jetzt schon gemacht und das
mache ich jetzt so damit ich einfach den
vollen geschmack mit dabei habe aber
eben nicht mehr so viel flüssigkeit also
dass das wasser einfach verdampfen kann
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
das kompott hersteller und dafür nehme
ich jetzt die äpfel und kann sie schälen
und dann in feine würfel schneiden
[Musik]
ich hab's geschafft eine schlange könnt
ihr das special effect 1
[Musik]
der apfelsaft kocht noch weiter vor sich
hin
und ich kenne jetzt in einem separaten
topf schon mal das komplott machen und
zwar gebe ich jetzt die apfelstücke hier
rein dazu etwas vanille extrakt für den
geschmack abgesagt dann noch der halbe
zitrone sagt also zitronensaft von einer
halben zitrone und zucker nach bedarf
also wenn ich es gerne säuerlicher mögt
macht ein bisschen weniger zucker und
wenn jetzt gerne etwas süßes mädchen
mehr das ganze jetzt kurz vermischen und
dann kann ich es auch kochen lassen und
etwa fünf bis zehn minuten weich kochen
bis die app leben weich sind wenn ihr
möchtet dass die apple aber noch ein
bisschen bis haben dann einfach nur 5
minuten kochen lassen hier drüben kann
ich jetzt schon mal die stärke mit den
gelben und dem zucker vermischen
das mache ich jetzt kurz hier in der
schüssel
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr ein bisschen was vom
apfelsaft damals zwar kurzinhalt aus das
reicht nämlich soweit nämlich ein
bisserl was vom apfelsaft und gebt den
hier dazu immer ganz wenig damit sich
das auch an die temperatur gewöhnen kann
und eben auch nicht klumpt
dann gebe ich noch mal ein löffel dazu
[Musik]
und dann kann die ganze massiv zurück in
den topf immer fleißig früher
jetzt kommt hier noch das 5 pulver mit
rein
ich hatte ich noch ein bisschen zucker
übrig und jetzt kann ich den pudding
einmal ganz kurz aufkochen lassen und
früher einfach währenddessen begann die
zeit
[Musik]
letzter pudding fertig und damit er
besser abkühlen kann fühle ich ihnen
jetzt in ein flaches gefäß und kann
ihnen dann direkt an der oberfläche mit
frischhaltefolie abdecken einfach damit
da eben keine haut bildet das
apfelkompott das kocht jetzt hier noch
vor sich hin
und wie gesagt lass ich es
wahrscheinlich so etwa 10 minuten
köcheln bis die äpfel weich sind und vor
allem dann auch bis die flüssigkeit
verdunstet und dann kann ich nämlich
gleich sobald die apple bereits sind
schon den muss ballack vorbereiten
[Musik]
für den belag brauche ich 150 gramm
walnüsse 75 gramm butter 50 gramm zucker
50 gramm honig und 30 milliliter sahne
die wahl ist die kann ich jetzt mache
ich jetzt einfach auf dem schneidebrett
mit einem messer
[Musik]
die wir alle sind gehabt jetzt kann ich
die restlichen zutaten also die butter
gemeinsam mit stimmen zucker und stimmt
honig und der sahne in einen topf geben
und einmal kurz aufkochen lassen
ja ich weiß eigentlich eigentlich fehlt
noch vanille aber ich habe jetzt schon
zimt mit dabei und vanille auch in den
äpfeln
da lassen wir jetzt im belag mal weg
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hätte hitze herunter
gestellt kann die wahl müsse einrühren
und einmal noch ganz kurz aufkochen
lassen
also nochmal auf hohe hitze stellen und
dann muss er jetzt im prinzip nur noch
darauf warten dass der hefeteig aufgeht
alles habe ich schon vorbereitet und
dann geht es gleich weiter
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist jetzt aufgegangen und
auch der rest ist gut vorbereitet
jetzt habe ich hier eine backform
bereits auf 24 cm durchmesser
eingestellt da kommt da jetzt rein und
wenn ihr einen festeren hefeteig
bevorzugt dann müsst ihr natürlich
ausrollen und zur eingeben aber ich kann
ihnen jetzt so einfach ganz einfach
verteilen und das geht jetzt einfach 5
weil er die hände ein bisschen fettet
und den teig dann an den rand tritt
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich den lust belag nehmen
und den ganz vorsichtig darüber
verteilen
[Musik]
den teig lasse ich jetzt noch mal etwa
zehn minuten stehen und dann kann ich
ihm bereits backen
das sieht doch schon mal gut aus so darf
da gucken jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 30 bis 35 minuten
[Musik]
der kuchen ist abgekühlt und ich habe
jetzt bereits mit der torten säge
durchgeschnitten und habe ich den oberen
teil weggehoben jetzt kommt hier ein
sauberer bergring außen herum
den stellt jetzt kurz zur seite und habe
ich jetzt bereits den pudding durch ein
hase gestrichen so werden einfach
klümpchen entfernt die mutter habe ich
jetzt mit einem handrührgerät schaumig
gerührt und jetzt kann ich bei niedriger
stufe einfacher esslöffel weise den
pudding angehören
[Musik]
jetzt die buttercreme bereit und die
kann ich jetzt auf den vorbereiteten
boden streichen
[Musik]
und jetzt verteile ich hier noch die
apfelstücke der russe
[Musik]
und bevor er zu trockenen deckel drauf
kommt teile ich dir nichts bereits in
tortenstücke ein damit ich später wenn
ich die torte schneide das einfach ein
bisschen einfacher habe
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die tortenstücke ganz
vorsichtig draufsetzen am besten 1
[Musik]
so ganz vorsichtig haben drücken und da
wir heute keinen mehr zum kaffeeklatsch
erwarten denke ich jetzt die torte ab
das geht am besten mit einem toten
retter oder mit einem silikon deckel und
kann sie jetzt über nacht kühlen aber
vier stunden reichen etwa auch aus jetzt
kann ich den bienenstich servieren und
das schneiden ist wirklich super einfach
da ich ja wirklich schon die
angeschnittenen tortenstücke habe und
jetzt kann ich den kuchen servieren
ich finde es bei buttercremetorte nimmer
ganz wichtig dass sie nicht ganz kalt
aus dem kühlschrank gegessen werden weil
er eben butter mit dabei steckt und der
geschmack entwickelt sich einfach viel
besser wenn das ganze schon ein bisschen
zimmer warm ist sie können die torte
ruhig eine stunde oder eine halbe stunde
bei raumtemperatur stehen lassen
im sommer natürlich nicht daran die
butter dachform läuft aber im herbst
klappt das wunderbare dann befragt das
nicht da zu probieren
also werde ich die torte probieren hier
sieht man dass die wahl es ist ein
bisschen vom deckel nach unten
geschwommen sind aber das ist gar nicht
schlimm so haben wir auch ein bisschen
krank im boden dabei und ich finde vor
allem diese kleinen apfelstücke richtig
genial
also ich probiere
[Musik]
ab 40 gramm versteht man nichts mehr
aber was ich euch hier noch zeigen
wollte das sind wie gesagt die
apfelstücke und ihr müsst ihr auf jeden
fall mit rein geben die haben so eine
richtig schöne säure
ihr könnt den zucker gerne auch
weglassen wie gesagt aber ich finde es
vom südens grad herr wirklich sehr
perfekt das stückchen werde ich mir
jetzt gleich aufheben und wird noch eine
tasse tee rauslassen wohl ich sagen eine
tasse kaffee rauslassen und dann
gemeinsam mit meinen gästen heute mittag
essen also falls sie die turtles
nachbacken wollt dann geht auch sally -
lok day
da steht alles noch mal ganz genau ich
finde sie wirklich super lecker vor
allem einfach mal eine schöne
alternative zum klassiker falls ihr
vielleicht auch mal ein rezept idee habt
zu einem klassiker oder eine abwandlung
dann schickt mir das gerne oder schreibt
einfach in die kommentare
ich finde wir sollten vielleicht eine
neue kategorie machen sallys classics &
jazz classics abwandlungen das kann man
ja auch machen
also viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis
zum nächsten mal ok eine gabel muss noch
essen tätig mit dem feld mittag auf aber
einige noch
[Musik]